you're going to blindly rank these
current and old Warriors players one
through five all right first one
Draymond Green five cuz I know you got
better ones coming four cuz he's the
four cuz he's the four next one Jordan
pool four cuz you said Draymond first
five yeah not a word no more Klay
Thompson oh three cuz he loves shooting
threes and there's probably two better
Warriors ahead of them I'm going go with
the two just because game six clay Steph
Curry Numero Uno none before him none to
come Numero Uno he's the best last spot
for both of you goes to Kevin Durant oh
Finals MVP twice in a row you can't
argue with that I give a three Clay's
more important and he's not a war no
more are you guys happy with your
ranking I kind of missed up but uh I
wish you would have said all the names
first but I'm not mad